james wrote in james says hey david do
you think more republicans don't stand
up to trump because they're spineless or
because they're unprincipled i actually
think there's a third option here that
you're not mentioning which is an
important one which is a lot of them do
agree with trump so there's 60 million
people or whatever that voted for Trump
who also vote for Senators and members
of Congress those senators and members
of Congress may have different reasons
why they are not standing up to Trump
with what exceptions like Justin Amash I
hope ever is I know it's not a mash I
think I pronounced it a mash and someone
said it's Amash Justin Amash and you
know rick wilson who i interviewed on
the program or Kellyanne Conway's
husband right there's a bunch of
different things going on some
Republicans in elected office aren't
standing up to Trump because they are
spineless they just are kind of go with
the flow and they don't want to rock the
boat and they don't want to possibly
have negative electoral repercussions
for their reelection campaigns if they
stand up to Trump
some are unprincipled in the sense that
it's all a power game to them it's sport
as I said before it's about wins and
losses it doesn't matter if Obamacare is
the same thing that was proposed by the
Heritage Foundation in the 90s which is
a very sort of corporatist center-right
plan to give tens of millions of new
customers to for-profit insurance
companies doesn't matter it's something
that Obama did it's a loss and the way
to put a box to check off a box on the
win column is to repeal it and get rid
of it even if you would kick tens of
millions of people off of health care
it's just sport and a lot of these
Republicans really are unprincipled and
we know that because they espouse one
set of principles and then often live by
a completely different set of principles
so that's group number two there are
also Republicans that just agree with
Trump I mean at this point we have to
sort of realize that there are some
Republicans who were just kind of
coalesced or emboldened to go public
with their beliefs and those beliefs
always matched many of Donald Trump's
beliefs they just weren't saying it out
loud now a lot of people in the Trump
era are saying the quiet part out lied
out loud
there are also Republicans that are I
mean at this point there is such a thing
as a Trump
Republican that is a wing of the
Republican Party and some Republicans
aren't standing up the Trump because
they simply agree with the guy so
spineless unprincipled or or agree with
him the answer is yes all three of these
depending who you're talking about for
different people it is different ones
and this is why I've been now saying for
months Trump is going to go eventually
it could be in a year and a half it
could be in five and a half years but
once he does that doesn't mean that
trumpism goes away unless we make it go
away unless we reject it completely and
vote out and not vote in all of the
people that are subscribing to this sort
of course and outlandish ignorant a
glorification that glorification of
ignorance that has taken place within
trumpian politics and this is why it's
really important to understand that
Donald Trump was always some Donald
Trump is a symptom and not the disease
as I've said before and even when you
cure the symptom of Trump by removing
him the disease that allowed him to come
to power in 2016 will still be there
unless we fully cure it and that is why
we need to be thinking beyond just Trump
in 2020 we need to be thinking about the
House and Senate we need to be thinking
about 2022 when Democrats will have more
possibilities to take over control of
the Senate which I just don't see any
path to doing in 2020 we've got to be
thinking bigger and beyond Trump and I
think a lot of people in our audience at
least from the emails I'm getting are
thinking bigger in that way which is a
good thing we've got a great bonus show
for you today become a member or a
patron to get instant access to the
bonus show I'll speak to you then one of
today's sponsors is impeach the card
slap game you can't slap Donald Trump in
real life but you can slap him in this
really funny and intelligent two-player
card game and you can get it for ten
percent off when you go to david
pakman.com slash impeach and use the
coupon code pakman show at checkout
all one word impeach the card slap game
is perfect for having friends over or
hanging out with family members who have
a sense of humor about Trump we've been
playing it at my place it currently has
a five out of five star rating on Amazon
I really don't think you'll be
able to find a game that does a better
job of satirizing today's political
climate in such an intelligent way I've
had a ton of fun with it and I think you
will too
you can tell a ton of time and careful
thought went into the game design and
the cartoon artwork and the humor it
never gets old because you're always
discovering new jokes and political
commentary within the game we were
talking to the creators of the game and
they said one of their goals was that
players might even learn something new
as they play I think it would make a
perfect gift for anyone really of any
political orientation just because of
how clever it is or you can get it for
yourself and have a really fun and witty
game to play when people come over get
impeach the card slap game by going to
david pakman.com slash impeach and get
10% off when you use the coupon code
pakman show at checkout that's all one
word Pakman show